in five four three two one hello
everybody is the genius brain podcast
everybody listens to win on the free
time I grew up in Sacramento California
where I got bullied a lot but then I was
like no you don't touch me if i'ma beat
you up if you touch me I'll break your
hands but then I would go back home get
in trouble then my dad would also beat
my ass until it turned bright red you
could see a glow in the dark just like
Rudolph's nose but um padam padam padam
did you think about that now that was
like off-the-cuff baby haha intro song
right there genius brain podcasts always
surprises people every day non-stop
konnichiwa konbanwa
ohayo gozaimasu I know I say uh how
about to do that
Nihao che che that's how I saw the car
sabaidee hello everybody welcome to
another episode the G spring podcast I
am your host we just ate a whole bunch
of Pollo Loco shoutouts to El Pollo Loco
one of the original chicken spots out
there we had a very interesting way of
eating it because if we're gonna provide
us utensils in our hands Indian Filipino
style baby that was very hard just try
to get the corn on your tortilla she was
so mad at me though El Pollo Loco
because I didn't want to get coleslaw oh
my gosh okay so we were getting a family
dinner combo right and therefore and we
ate it all there are two side dishes you
could choose and I told him I was like
okay let's get coleslaw and he's like
can we get the dinner combo and then she
asked for what size you want he's like
oh rice and corn and I'm like dude get
the coleslaw and he looked at me he's
like coleslaw it's not got hair I'm like
oh why don't I get the privilege to
choose one when there are two side
dishes I think you're being ridiculous
and I was so pick I wasn't pissed I was
upset I'm like excuse me I do have
boys hoist up oh oh I do have a voice
I'm snuffing out your voice for coleslaw
I told him wow this is and he's like oh
you're Bank making a big deal of it's
nothing it's just cold some like that's
how it starts when yeah this is what she
does she does it's just like it's the
little things that or in her mind and
that pebble just starts to pick up a lot
of debris hams a boulder you know if you
say in like bad people out work
environment for example that's how we us
ladies take it be like oh yeah that's
just how it is but really that is now
how it should be we should be equal and
not take over the choices I'm on in my
coleslaw I said I wanted coleslaw I'm
gonna kick you in your stomach no this
is I'm serious because we've been happy
okay we've been having some serious
conversation at work and I've just been
thinking my previous works too like just
experience of all the things that I've
encountered where people brought up I'm
like oh yeah I've experienced that but I
thought I was just oh because that's
just who he she is or because that's
just what the society is that's just
what it's like but technically it's not
right what are you talking about it's
frigging coleslaw dude
oh so it's 10 o'clock at night I was
starving and I really wanted coleslaw
you could have just been like okay like
a gender issue is frigging coleslaw dude
we had an option of two sides and I was
like eh this one's better and then
you're like I bought coleslaw yes oh
yeah it's all you could have said was
let's just get the coleslaw on the side
I'm like ooh no you didn't you'd even
give me a choice you said coleslaw sucks
here yeah I'm trying to warn you and did
we finish it you finished it I ate the
corn in the rice I saw you eat that
coleslaw yeah I did not enjoy it then
why'd you eat it I had some should have
been all for me he was a very hard
person dude this is the thing about her
she loves picking fights picking fights
his Muriel's thing she could find a flaw
in a perfect dine
if she wanted to every morning every
morning she greets me with what did what
I did wrong that's my good morning
you know I'd you know you did this just
like what how the bird the birds are
chirping our Armenian neighbors are
yelling at each other it's a beautiful
day the guy screaming to the other guy
about the bike you know the dad of the
Sun fighting is fighting about the bike
take the bike please just take your kid
wants the bike I don't want to take the
BAI dad
just there's no [ __ ] bike if you
don't take the [ __ ] bike thank the
bike I don't want the bike dad [ __ ] it
I'm gonna go what are you gonna do run
me over you talk to your father this way
you talk to the older generation this
way david wakes up hey take the bike
every morning that's what they you or do
you speak to your father this way I
don't want the [ __ ] bike dead dead
silence 10 seconds later just take the
bike well I've been waking up a lot
earlier than them so I don't hear those
fight anymore all I hear is whining and
crapped clean up every morning no you're
the one who decided that you wanted a
puppy I did which is so shocking so I
have a puppy
her name is Riley she's freaking
adorable but damn she's a lot of work
Odie was gonna be a lot of work yeah I
should have watched all those videos of
like things I wish I have known before I
got my puppy but you know but you need
like dogs were gonna be a lot of work
yeah well I mean honestly I wanted to
get it because it was gonna be a good
baby step before maybe I want a kid
right now it's a maybe because this is
freaking hard and it baby is a whole
different level because their poop is
much bigger and you have her for the
rest of your life so yeah at this house
it's just the dog it's just a dog you
see how she exaggerated things all the
time this is this is her life she just
like she gets
so man she goes like I told you if you
leave the rock out she's gonna pee on it
yeah but you don't understand though you
don't got the whole life for the dog you
know and teach the dog what is properly
what's not her but then there are baby
steps you just don't have a puppy be
like mark you go and party away really
how he does have you owned and he always
bring this because so many puppies
because of dogs because it's important
no I understand it's important but what
did you what else did you say you said
I'm not gonna take care of the puppy so
all the way he hey let me finish all the
pee and the poop and every other crap
that comes from Reilly I take care of it
so putting that rug is an extra work
brewing and I and you know what's gonna
be worse than the mother said she is not
ready let's do baby step because she
could 80% of the time she goes potty or
if she goes to the party suction
correctly but 20% she still needs work
so having that rug is just gonna confuse
her and all that pillows cushions extra
confuse by the way it doesn't get easier
so like I said for you you have to be if
you're a sieve okay with with with with
the dog right mm-hmm because if it
wasn't for you you would've left her in
that small cage and I told you to make
the area bigger and then this is what
she does that is the most annoying thing
about her I tell her these by the way in
my lifetime I've owned all eight healthy
dogs every single one was potty-trained
perfectly lived for a very [ __ ] long
time they and six of them are still
around right now this woman what she'll
do is this it's the most I'm not you can
even ask her best friend about this [ __ ]
let's so we'll do this right I go okay
so when you do this isn't this is
because she'll ask me and she goes
that's not what I read cool goes away
a week later she'll come back hey guess
what you know what we should do and I'm
like you son of a gun I literally just
told you that
and you're and that she loves spewing
information back at me that I already
told her okay here's the thing I like to
get as much information as possible so
yes I asked you because I respect your
opinions I wasn't gone for two years to
you by the way go ahead yeah exactly so
I respect your advice and your opinion
so that's why I
ask you if I don't live a freak would I
ask you and waste my time I don't I
barely have time to sleep to eat as you
see you see me you're you know you
witnessed me share you guys have time to
sleep but she's a helicopter mom so
that's why I stresses her out continue
well if not that she'll pee and poo
everywhere and then you'll get mad or we
crepe trainers
anyways so there are options excuse me
I'm trying to talk stop butting it okay
I just say go at all like I said I
respect your advices that's why I get
yours but I also like to look at others
people because not that's okay you just
you're misquoting it but go ahead
continue misquoting okay I love how you
have to still say everything do you see
this guy he still needs to but it and
say what he has to say respect you're
wrong me okay so that's I well you're
being disrespectful of me because you're
not saying it how it actually is but
I'll just say that go ahead thank you
for proving my point okay so that's the
bad said I like to get my information
from multiple people because not only
one solution works for all dogs so I
like to have different options if that
doesn't work let's try this one for
example when you know Riley is a biter
she's a hella biter and it hurts so I
asked David suffice what do you do and
he said you would what did you say he
like push onto her collar so she gets
kind of shocked or surprised and then
she knows oh that's not what you what
she should be doing I was like okay and
then I saw I also read online that you
could also train her we're basically
kind of persuade her to chew on her toys
or her bully sticks and keep doing that
repetitively so that she understands oh
these are the stuff that I need to chew
on so I tried that first didn't work so
I tried his advice it worked
kind of but I think it's more effective
so I used your advice now I gotta try to
things to understand what works and what
doesn't right so that's what I'm trying
about what I'm talking about those oh
can I speak now you have been speaking
so it doesn't matter
you might completely ignore what I said
what was the funny funny thing about you
I didn't say that you can't try new
things I said the funny thing about you
is you taking information I already told
you and trying to teach me something I
taught you telling you like please can I
talk now you need the funny part is is
when you go hey did you know and I'm
like did you know I told you that that's
the funny part
I'm not a in your own world my funny
story and anecdote is saying the funny
thing about her mm-hmm it's the fact
that you tell me information that I told
you like I didn't tell you I'm like I'm
the one who told you that that's what
I'm saying
you also said it offline here you also
said that it's annoying that you asked
for advice and you go and do something
else and really no but I read this
that's why I'm telling you that I like
to know different out she's just like
how people like to have different
options of food I like different office
training okay and also you make me feel
by every time I ask you questions I
don't make you feel bad you feel no you
feel bad you know who I am sensitive
exactly very very sensitive exactly
especially lack of sleep this is what's
gonna happen we have a kid this is it
this is the exact one I'm sorry it's not
when it's oh no that's a when it's an F
it's a when snip-snip on the condoms
anyways
Oh hail naw I'm throwing all those away
oh I don't think so
anyways so one of the things that I
really wanted to talk about was
specifically our favorite show once
again Harris house this happened like a
few like a few weeks ago and obviously
there's a lot of other tragedies and a
lot of things that are being highlighted
right now in the media but this was
pretty devastating for me only because
we have spoken about this girl on this
podcast before
Hana Hana so Hana on this show the
terrorist house or terrace house I'm
sorry is as a Japanese reality show
which if you guys haven't listened to
this podcast you know I'm [ __ ] mad
into this like I wanted to apply like if
I spoke Japanese I'd be on that show in
a hot second just dirty [ __ ] I mean
technically as of now they're not
permanently closed their season about to
have me and that's gonna be dope but
anyways so Han now
she actually a committed suicide due to
a lot of pressures on the show so a lot
of people were a quote-unquote
cyberbullying her and she you know there
was a lot of alarming things that you
could see on her Instagram or social
media that kind of led people to believe
that she was gonna do something like she
she had so actually I saw this I saw her
insta story still on her Instagram after
the news came out and so actually people
found out within 24 hours and what I saw
is that her insta story she took a photo
of pretty photo of herself and her cats
and then the next story was she wrote
farewell which is silent at up that's
usually like the end but you usually
don't say that phrase unless you're not
gonna see that person again
so really like when you say it like say
Oh nada like that it's like done yeah
like for example cuz you know in
Japanese culture usually for friends you
say month on then means let's meet again
again you know so if you say sayonara is
farewell it's just like it's uh
Americans no we don't say that but yeah
you know it's interesting on this
podcast when you're at home and you
speak used your so loud with your this
podcast you're like yes so like when you
know I was super loud it's the emotion
that I emot-- know but you won't you
speak normally at the house you speak
like a megaphone somebody's on this
podcast you're like yeah okay so with
this girl that had that so I set the
volume for your regular speaking voice
and then for some reason on this podcast
you're a different person okay
all right let me just boy is that good
because I hear myself going back and
forth on oh ah I just want you to speak
like how you'd normally
like that either
so Oh me I'm talking about something
serious so I'm trying to like you know
call my mood down do you have you do at
the copier that's fine too so before we
do his podcast we do a Mic Check
and then she's talking I I level it out
to how loud she's gonna get whatever and
then for some reason right when the
camera starts she goes okay guys that
way you okay so either way yeah no it
goes we don't they yell I go why can't
you just become regular voice whispering
to the Michael you're screaming oh my so
that's that hey we're talking about
specific serious conversation here that
said yeah so sayonara means as soon as I
saw that I was like holy cow people are
gonna like think of something and I
think that's why people they were able
to find out what happened to her within
24 hours because obviously her story
said something I don't never post and
she might have had it was a post with
her cat yeah with her cat and then no
joke like within 12 hours because I saw
the historian says 12 hours before she
hung herself right or the details they
just said they didn't say she committed
suicide they just said she has passed
away and please respect the family for
privacy the interesting thing is about
the show is that it's so transparent you
get to see a lot of lot of them right I
think with other reality TV shows
because it's a lot of these situations
are you know exaggerated and exacerbated
like you could you people kind of live
in this world of oh they're playing a
character or they're doing this for a
lot of attention so um in that kind of
sense when I think I feel like for
American reality TV stars when they get
bullied they kind of know what they're
getting into right yeah some people when
it comes to terrace house they have a
goal of becoming famous and they're very
transparent with it we might there's
this beauty of the show
extremely honest something all I have a
band I'm a part of a band I want to give
this bad recognition I want to learn
about myself that's why I came to
terrace house right and a host also
mention it's like oh he if they're doing
something like skeptical the host would
point it out they could see it they're
like oh I think he's just saying that
for PR reasons yeah and then yeah so a
lot of people who are in bands when they
go ahead and apply to the show they had
that goal of getting their band
recognition for Hana it was for women's
wrestling so they had these goals I
think then one of the things that they
don't really expect or they think that
they expect because not only her but
there was another person on this season
too she left early because she couldn't
handle the pressure
or she couldn't handle Emme yeah and we
couldn't handle the pressure or she
couldn't handle the fact that other
people were seeing in a light that she
didn't view was really her or she didn't
realize that that's how she came off to
other people right because you're
learning a lot about yourself so these
people are on the show has they're in
the house they can see the episode
within a week yeah and they're watching
how the hosts talk about them yeah about
how they behave and how they actually
look like when it comes to human
interaction because a lot of us we don't
know how we're like when we speak to
other people for example we I just got
done with a meeting today and there was
a conversation about how I speak and a
lot of people who know me they
understand and I'm very very candid so
when I when I speak in these means I'm
like okay I go well these are the
problems I want to fix right but well
sometimes when you do that in a group
setting and people don't know you they
get their feelings hurt they start to
feel you know like they're
underappreciated or whatever so I don't
know about these things and tell us
address to me so I can only imagine what
it's like when somebody is in US and
they could actually see video footage of
them mm-hmm and how they interact and so
that's what happened with Emmy and with
Hana if you guys don't know um and you
obviously if you're in the States you're
not gonna know this unless you had a VPN
and you got to watch the episodes that
were released in Japan and in other
countries there was I I have a big
feeling the reason why she was getting
bullied a lot was because of a very very
specific incident on the show so there's
a stand-up comic on there named Kai
right terrible stand-up comic by the way
that boy is hot trash
you get better I think I don't know you
know he has a lot of work to do on his
craft he sucks he's green as hip yeah I
know people were green though there
weren't they or not everybody got a star
somewhere okay you're not like this
genius person from the get-go like you
okay I'm not I wasn't a genius
either I'm saying for him he lacks
perspective and nuance you know and for
any any comic there's comics why don't
find funny but I can be like oh I could
see why that's funny to somebody yeah
I'm pretty like I think he enjoys
stand-up comedy because of what it did
for him in his life and he wants to
return that favor by doing stand-up
comedy himself fair however stand-up
comedy I truly believe like fighting any
type of art drawing whatever does
require a certain amount of talent and
then hard work gets you there through
the rest of it right for him he's at a
high disadvantage because he is not a
funny person less yeah yeah and that
kind of goes along with the part of the
drama that happened on terrace house do
you want to talk about that yeah of
course so what happened with in that
situation was so Kai is somebody on the
show that number one like I said I'm
talking about him as a stand-up comic
I'm not saying he can't improve or
whatever but he was he's brave though
cuz he went to another country doing
stand-up comedy in these small little
clubs inviting his friends out to watch
him do stand-up which is very [ __ ]
brave I commend him for that a lot
however hot trash bomb and constantly
right and it was just terrible like if
you guys watch it it's gonna make your
skin crawl
yeah but I think with him number one one
of the habits that he had that I really
didn't like was him making excuses about
well he couldn't pay for certain things
cuz he didn't have a lot of money right
yeah and he's somebody out there who
believes that number one his talent can
get him so he goes well I can't work
because I'm working every day to work on
my stand-up and he advise people out to
see is Denham it's it's [ __ ] right but
then I look at him and I'm like that's
the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever
heard of my life yeah [ __ ] when
I was doing stand-up I was a full-time
[ __ ] student I was working at my
parents door and I had a part-time job I
don't want to hear [ __ ] because number
one the reason why he also failed in
stand-up comedy and because he was like
I'm sitting here writing material
you have no material right because
you're not living life you're not
working you're not meeting people you're
not talking to people yeah he's always
he's always talking about someone else's
life which doesn't make sense because
then you can't make fun of them because
it's not you exactly it doesn't come
from a place of honesty so it's these
comedies very dishonest so for example
he's he's trying to do this the style of
comedy where shock value right you're
just trying to be an edge Lord so he
goes into this comedy club and his sets
about Japanese where the workmen where
men salary men right which is like
you're nine to fivers right he goes
what's its Japanese salary man why are
you guys just like how do you guys not
kill yourself like go home to your wife
and all she's like first of all bro you
don't work a nine-to-five you probably
never have and number two you don't even
have a wife yeah though his nuances his
perspective on a subject doesn't have
any comedy because there's no truth in
it you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about his crowd or all nine to
fivers and they could smell it on it
yeah so that's the kind of just to put
that in frame it into a little bit of
their frustration was that's his type of
laziness he has an excuse for why it's
not it's not because he suck at his
craft
it's his excuses that comes around where
he said he can't do anything else
because of his he needs to work on his
crap so not excuse for his laziness yeah
so a lot of the roommates are seeing
this and it doesn't really show in the
episodes but then you could tell that
it's starting to build up of their anger
and like everything that likes you know
the lack of responsibility he has and
there's an incident where basically Hana
forgets to put her costume that she used
or she wore at the Tokyo Dome for her
was a competition she's she's by the way
she's a professional performance rush
like WWE and she got this really special
like only hand made only for her [ __ ]
expensive by the way uh a costume for
her arrest competition in Tokyo Dome and
Tokyo Dome being in there and performing
is a huge thing in Japan I remember like
back before social media I was around
when Capeside it's a square garden yeah
basically it's like that means you made
it so she was so proud of it and then
she was you know she
to wash it for the next competition and
she forgot to put in the dryer and next
thing you know her costume got really
shrunk and she was upset because someone
decided to not look inside we're inside
the washing machine and just throw
everything in the dryer now granted it
was her responsibility and that is her
like a responsibility I'm not oh this is
this is this is where I believe that a
lot of people felt like she was out of
line and this is probably where the
cyber bullying started once again this
is just an explanation I'm not
justifying anything so she kind of comes
in superhot um she just sits there she's
super quiet and you know Kai comes back
in and she goes off on this guy like
yeah you're lazy you're dumb she says
everything is she actually kind of puts
her hands on him too yes I really didn't
[ __ ] like and he just sit there it's
like what the [ __ ] yes be single zona
yeah and you know everybody else too
even the host was like it was odd for
them to watch her treat him like that
because it was almost like she was
sitting on her high horse as if she had
no personal responsibility in this yeah
and she kind of just put out that she
goes yeah I should have taken out the
dryer however you're that you're the
dumbass that left it in there you're not
even sorry yeah and I think like that
gonna sit well with a lot of the
audience cuz it didn't sit well with me
either
because we saw what happened like she
went on a trip and she forgot to put it
in the dryer because she was too busy
prepping for that exactly so in my mind
because this is how I view it because
I've lived with people and she's never
lived with people either up into that
point it's like that's your
responsibility you left it in the washer
and it was one item yeah when you leave
things in a big washer and is one item
you can't see it it's it happens all the
time like you it might be stuck on the
side or whatever yeah and if you just
people typically just throw stuff in and
it's a house full of a lot of people so
and it wasn't done on purpose with like
bad intention it was an accident it just
happened to be a really expensive one so
there's fault at both ends you know yeah
it's it's fault on both ends and I think
like the way that she handled it didn't
sit well with that with a lot of the
Japanese crowd because it was there
wasn't a certain level of personal
responsibility there and for a lot of I
you know I read comments from a lot of
young people to they're like no it's
completely his fault it's like yeah
you're [ __ ] 12 years old you never
lived with people well that's a thing
he's 20 what 20 - yeah she's 22 she's
super yeah
he didn't live with anyone her circle is
so small small she lived in a bubble
because she was a restless since she was
born basically because her parents one
of her parents are her dad her mom yeah
it was a famous wrestler so as you know
a lot of like professional sport players
they live in a bubble so they don't know
much of like how to socialize with
outside people and so I mean I'm looking
at it that kind of point of view I like
Shawn she's so young like there's so
much for her to learn I hope she learns
a lot from this but instead she takes it
so bad to her heart that she couldn't
handle it because it was coming so much
at once and I feel like for her to like
as a young person and mind you when I'm
telling you this story it's not my
personal feelings I'm trying to get into
the psyche of what people were seeing at
why they started cyber bullying her I'm
sorry bullying is [ __ ] dumb in the
first place you bunch of so easy to do a
pusses anyways like for her I feel I
don't know her but a lot of it was the
cyber bullying was a huge factor and I
think like she probably felt a little
guilty after having probably watching
I'll be watching it look just like how
Amy did right and I'm only speculating
at this point too you know Kai has the
Chi you know I feel like he didn't do
anything wrong I [ __ ] up and washing
her clothes but there's a lot to that
point it was it was an honest mistake
warm but just to give you guys another
perspective too he's been a habitual
[ __ ] so that was just the last straw
that broke the camel's hump it was just
her reaction just seemed a little bit
much for what the situation called for
it was she wasn't blowing out cuz of
that one thing it was just everything
just you just build everything like him
not paying split bills and stuff him
just being and you know cuz everybody in
that house - is a professional they work
really really really hard and there's
another guy to name hon son there's a
hunts not in the Hansa I love huntin
this is look boss pervert guy [ __ ] boy
the beer guy
this dude by the way is a [ __ ] weirdo
man like this guy he was covering a lot
of his bills when they went to a trip to
either Osaka or Kyoto right and I think
because there was no communication
he actually communicated with boss like
hey I want you to come to be my wingman
and I'll just pay for everything and
them they were like well why isn't he
splitting the bill but he already worked
out with boss that hey I'm just coming
along he knows I don't have money he
didn't pay for me because he makes good
money and I'm just here to be his
wingman mm-hmm so for them they thought
that he was being really ungrateful but
he didn't to his argument that he said
he goes I told him thank you like he
knows I'm very appreciative of him but
but there are seeing like oh just like
small actions such as like Oh helping
with the luggage but then he was like
walking ahead of them and it's just a
little things that they were watching
where it's very I feel like it's very
Asian culture thing yeah yeah yeah small
gestures really means a lot this podcast
is brought to you by skill share what is
skill share you ask it is an online
learning community that offers
memberships with meaning skills share
offers classes designed for real life so
you can learn the things you want at
your pace based on your busy routine I
hate rush learning I want to learn on my
own time I know a lot of people out
there have hobbies or even a side hustle
that you want to get into but you don't
know where to start we'll go to skill
share and look up the courses that you
know will get you pointed in the right
direction right now I've moved on to a
course called design great stuff because
I'm thinking about doing some great
merchandise for this podcast and well
what do you know
how convenient I can learn from a
seasoned professional on Skillshare one
of the things that always gets me to
stop doing something is not knowing
where to begin and I got these courses
on Skillshare and helps out a lot so
explore your creativity get to three
months of premium membership at
Skillshare comm slash brain that's two
whole months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes for free get
started and joined today by heading to
Skillshare dot-com slash brain that's
two free months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes at Skillshare
dot-com slash Brittany yeah
it's also he's from Arizona too so like
he was kind of like in a low point at
that time cuz he was just like he cried
at that trip yeah yeah he's at a very
low point specifically be in his career
like he knows that he wasn't doing well
he knows that he was bombing in I think
when I just to give him credit to like
what I liked about him - he was
perceptive to criticism right especially
when the VB came in and she kind of came
in hot with some advice he's like okay I
agree with that like and he was going to
try to work
I think the sad thing about Hana
situation was you know you're kind of
put into the scenario and on a reality
TV show or I don't think they realized
that with this quote-unquote fame
there's a lot of positive but there's a
[ __ ] ton of negative that you have yeah
on stantly and if you're not really
prepping you're not really ready for
that mm-hmm and you go well I didn't
sign up for this it doesn't matter what
you signed up for when your name in your
face and on your business and your life
is out there you're leaving yourself up
for the public to judge who you are
period end of story and it's such an
organic thing that I'm sure that you
know Tara Stiles is not gonna think oh
this is gonna happen it's just so
organic how they how they shoot this and
edit it that you just don't know what
the audience is gonna think look I've
had conversations with people to where
you know um you know people have meshes
mean cuz I'm like you know I'll make a
joke about somebody's content or
whatever parody or whatever you know
what I mean yeah and there's like oh
like I put a lot of heart and thought
into that sucks that you do stat I'm
like but listen once you put your stuff
out to the public eye on entertainment
scale it's up to us to interpret it
however we want that's the beauty and
the negative part about your art right
if I put out a film right like I didn't
cook right I put that film out and it
had a 20 percent on Rotten Tomatoes that
[ __ ] would hurt me right yeah but I
can't be mad for for people for feeling
that my film was shitty yeah you put it
out there so that we could have an
opinion yeah you have an opinion it's a
lot I could think it's trash to it I
could be upset but it's not gonna kill
me on the inside because I understand
the relationship that I have with
putting my stuff out there for that
though it you're not cyber bullying
cyber bullying is a whole different
thing people could say or you put it out
there so we could write whatever we want
that's different though cuz like I feel
like a lot of people what they think is
that it's like oh you're you know when
you're having that opinion of your
content the content that they provide
out there they would think like oh
because I've seen some comments that's
very interesting maybe like dang like
what if that person when I'm it's a
female what if that person was your
daughter why don't you think that's like
a horrible thing to say about your
daughter I was like well she kind of put
it out there like it's not that he's
hating or it's just putting an opinion
there's no it's not that it's not
empathetic right it's more like
you walked into an entered payment space
and this is what this platform is more
and it kind of sucks that nobody preps
maybe some of these classes about hey
when you're on this show understand that
these are the consequences that yeah
you're gonna get a lot of publicity but
people are gonna have opinions about you
and you'd be okay with living with that
um and it's it's it's harsh it's hard
man I I feel for that girl a lot and you
know even when we were talking about her
previously on the podcast right about
like Oh like we were saying if our like
the host perspective on the show but we
also mentioned she's only 22 yeah she's
a very young person she's only making
mistakes that young people make and I
think we were trying to view her at an
adult lens of like she should know
better how she's [ __ ] 21 yeah and she
puts up this you know image of her being
strong which physically she is probably
wore out but she's very innocent the
inside I mean look at what's that deal
with she had a crush on Bo like she was
nothing but this innocent girl couldn't
stop giggling yes that's how innocent
and pure or just naive she is that any
attack it would kill her
and she got a lot of attention to a
point where I saw her drive she disabled
comments yeah so only her friends could
comment her on her so I feel so sorry
for her like she hasn't gone through so
much she hasn't gone through any
experiences nobody nobody's really ever
prepared for that stuff like even for me
you know when I get bad comments which I
get a [ __ ] ton of them - mm-hmm yeah
heat it up I get heat it up but that I
you know for me the cool thing is is I
trying to make it into a game it's like
how can I install this person and make
them feel like [ __ ] yeah and then bother
them for the rest of their life
so it's my part of this conversation
what do you mean cuz that's what you do
to me what do you mean you talk back to
me in a way where you know like oh it's
gonna make her frustrated no yes yeah no
I do not ya know I just like how you but
in my conversation well I do that
because you're doing something very bad
okay so anyway yeah she messed up
recently - is she had to apologize she
was so mean to me recently and don't
even go there yeah I did apologize I
didn't you're being really mean and
all you do is keep joking and joke I
don't I can't tell when he jokes or not
because I'm always serious now cuz I got
no time to joke I'm a mom yes that's why
I'm saying if we have a kid because
apparently I'm the only parent you need
a relaxed man
you need say you need that chill man I
get you sorry baby can i I gotta bring
it off you gotta relax a little bit baby
why you wanted me to up my voice right
so I'm upping it I didn't mean the
intensity I just meant the volume it
comes with it yeah but um you know in
her case it's it's it's you know it's
those people are that we I think we see
a lot they kind of put up this front
that they're always strong that they
tend to be the weakest when it's behind
closed doors yeah and I think that's why
people say like hey check up on your
friends I get a little I'll be honest
with you guys if I could have a moment
honesty when people check up on me I get
[ __ ] weirded out like they're like cuz
you know they see me I get stressed out
and they're like hey max wanna make sure
are you doing okay and the first thing
and I think it's because we grew up with
like macho dads and like macho korean
men when they ask me they go hey are you
doing well the first thing I would say
is make shut the [ __ ] up they're trying
to just be there for I know I'm not mad
at them but it's more like you feel
weird but I think you gotta you gotta
you gotta work with your heart there no
I do work with my heart like I stressed
out and I have my ways of distressing I
appreciate it a lot but I I go so fast
my dear that is you know you with your
road rage and the last time you saw road
rage oh actually no just your road rage
of speaking not like actually driving
and like you know if something doesn't
get delivered on time you get so pissed
about that it's like it comes out of
nowhere you're like hi dear I did it I'm
like are you talking about yourself are
you talking about me right now yeah I
think you're talking about you right now
this is her by the way the dog does
doglike things right collapses to the
floor and buries her face in a pillow
and I'm like hey yo chill yeah you could
say that because you don't clean
her poo and pee from 6 o'clock in the
morning till 9 o'clock at night and I
quote what she told me about she goes I
don't want you also taking care of the
dog because I want to talk to love be
boys and it loves you
ok never said that yes you did because
you said ok better Veda
you better stop lying on gas right now
oh don't clap at me like a seal all
right don't you dare clap at me like a
seal I'll roundhouse kick you out of
here are you insane
oh by the way we have a dog her name is
boonie and she Sacramento California
right who's interrupting who right now I
think there's habits that you have that
I also have that you had that I also
have is over here doing the same [ __ ] to
me
that she hates she goes let me tell you
all right sure I think you guys
information oh really
what are you sound like right now this
is some day job loose I think this is
dangerous I think we have a day job
who's right now this is crazy isn't it
see she bites dude the hypocrisy the
hypocrisy continue well just wait
anyways so I have it oh we're doing
interrupted games again huh so we have a
dog yet dog's name is boonie ok her full
name
boonie bear so booty bear her name is a
pony no no no no he's boonie bear oh ok
so mean so bunny bear is our dog right
and she she got so upset because when um
when I had her boonie really likes me a
lot
yeah so when we would walk she would try
to walk ahead of me with the dog but
booney would stop and wait for me to
come and so because she remembers this
traumatizing experience dog like you may
be in additional information on that
hold up my talk yeah you'd like to
interrupt you two interrupted
huh that's your superhero name
interrupter test is that what we do it
right now right cuz I remember somebody
telling me that they hate it when people
just interrupt and they don't let them
talk and said I am a woman hey respect
me as the woman that I am don't you dare
speak over email then go so
remember she did it like that and so she
goes I was Pacific said I want the new
doctor love me more than you is what you
said the most thing I've ever heard of
my life so that's why I took a backseat
in taking care of the dog there okay so
the first thing boonie
my oh so the when he was talking about
the example of me walking the dog I told
him was like I oh I've always wanted to
walk a dog so okay I was so excited to
walk boonie
because it just seems so fun and she's
cute it didn't work she wouldn't walk
because why David was behind me and she
was waiting for David to come along
so unless David is ahead of us she would
not walk and Damon likes to be behind me
because he likes to take his time so I
got really sad I got really sad and I
was like damn I won't I'm not putting
this on my bucket list that I want to
have a dog that would walk with me but
she can by the way as long as she does
it more frequently she only tried once
what does that mean
is that a new curse you you don't talk
to me like that
hey that's what I told him and what he
said I've become when I shut up was
completely wrong what I says I want to
be the master of a dog as well because
when he let me say thanks you tell me to
shut up snippy you go ahead
so oh my god execute execute execute hey
sidetrack don't do that to me and I
can't for what I'm laughing okay so I
told okay see I lost my train of thought
so when I told him about the bunny
example he said it was because I'm the
master and that's why she waits for me I
was like okay well I want to be a master
of a puppy too or a dog and so my best
friend decided that she wanted to get a
puppy and I went with her and there were
two of them and love at first sight I
looked at it she looked at me we wanted
it I looked at David it was like oh gosh
you both are gonna get one yep so I did
and I told him I said hey I want to be
the master of this dog so what are you a
[ __ ] Pokemon master what are you
talking about I want to be the master of
this dog I wanted to be the the one you
know the one that always falls around
nah continue shut up hey snip you stab
you so I told him let me do all the work
because also it's a baby step to have a
kid and let me know what the stress is
like and look what happened now she
doesn't want children mm-hmm and he acts
on to that stress by saying
whoo so I have five dogs and trained at
whosoever had the license of training
because everything I'm like dude if you
can't help then Ellie shut up I'm trying
to help but what happens is I'd you
literally do everything three weeks
later what I've already told you David
David told you
you remember that lunch example the
lunch meeting you had today how you
couldn't explain something because you
knew that someone else could explain it
better without hurting someone's emotion
or feelings yeah yeah I get that from
you yeah I say things really nice to you
though no you actually say where there's
an
elephant in the room there is no
elephant in this town is out there wait
you little puppy and her name is Rani I
have a witness where even my best friend
said I could see how that could hurt you
because she knows that you're very
sensitive and that's a wrap
well that's not a rabbit so anyway so
yeah that's why I asked him not to help
me not because so if you ask me not to
help you how can you get mad from me not
helping you ooh did we just do that but
I just checkmate your ass just openly a
minute she asked me not to help and
she's mad at me for not helping Wow
amazing let's talk about that butterfly
in the sky
this is why I don't do podcasts with you
it's so much work I didn't get mad at
you because you know I wasn't again why
it was because you would say crap that
would make me feel horrible and also you
will say things it's like Kenzo nuts I'm
sorry sorry that's not the right word um
you're very good at pointing at things
where make someone feel hurt as if like
oh I'm doing a horribly I must be really
bad at this because you have trained
five dogs had a training license love I
that's always your backup I'm like
freaked I get it okay you are the master
of training I get it but you don't
master but I do have experience in that
I ask your advice but I also look around
for other advices what is wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with that
right
other thanks to my dear I did that is
not the argument that's not the thing I
just made a funny little nuance about
how you would just regurgitate something
I told you and that you said that you
learned from somebody else I told you
that I didn't say that I might have said
something but like hey I learned this it
might be from you that's why I find it
so funny I don't remember that might be
the case you know me I'm dory so that
could be the case and I also find it a
problem when you ask for advice and I
tell you it and then you go that's not
what I read it's like why did you ask me
then and that's not a deer that is
quoting you
whatever you quoting this literally said
that's not what I read in that type of
tone I'm like then why'd you ask why'd
you ask if you wanted me to ask you
because I really liked you to ask my
dear
I trained 5/8 at because oh really cuz
let's talk about this this girl for some
reason things that dogs won't eat food
so I would wake up and I would see this
girl hand feeding this dog as this she's
a paraplegic like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like this dot because I have a dog
at home right her name is Mimi and she's
a self rating self-regulating eater so
that means that this dog will eat when
the dog is hungry there's a few dollars
that are like that some dogs are just
ravenous and they eat all the time
other dogs will eat when they want and
I've seen her eat her kibble before so
this dog low and behold when she falls
asleep I just watched the dog for about
an hour and then finally she gets up she
sniffs the bowl and she eats all of her
[ __ ] food and then when she wakes up
I'm like hey guess what the dog did the
dog ate sure that is true that's why I
left it out which is what all day yeah
like I said I wanna try like I said I
gotta try things to know what is right
also adding on top of that let me tell
you what's not right your dog is if it
doesn't have a mouth and lays itself
it's only living creature and I want to
make sure it doesn't die on my head that
Hannibal and it won't die because he's
eating that food before and it likes it
like I said you had five dogs to Train I
hadn't 0.2 frame so yes I would be a
little bit more worried I told you on
top of that I switched her food to a
different brand I just did some more
research of what brand type of food
dogs are puppies like more I got this
brand she's been eating on the spot
every single meal that's fine too but
she also liked her other kibble too but
and she would eat it that's true but I
found see and so I found solutions why
can't you just let me do
a month straight she has been feeding
this is Todd PI head it is the oddest
thing I've ever seen in my life
she goes individual kibble pieces I know
the ball is gone do you have any you
guys you have to understand princess
I never see somebody feed a dog like
that before and that's how I spend my
day and then I come back she goes I
spend so much time with this dog I'll
bite girl that's not you the dogs well
that's your fault also I felt like the
puppy was looking at me be like fine
right now
because you're feeding me and I was just
having it one by one but really I'm not
hungry
it's what I think she said really
because now she's like oh I want more
food she kept like bringing the bowl to
me she's like food anyway oddest person
I've ever been a month no differently I
know I agreed that you know you should
find your own ways and try to learn
things yourself I get it I'm saying that
the funny thing is is you're asking me
and then you go well that's not what I
heard and I'm like - why'd you ask
multiple times we could even write a set
that if you just say you can't you
should do the idea we could we could you
know what next time we're gonna have
your best friend here and then she will
she knows because she's very good luck
bringing her in here she is there I
don't know and I'm like why do you keep
doing that hey do you think about this
is my game because I don't remember you
should know this by now I do it because
I don't remember it dogs been chewing up
her hand like a chew toy and I might do
this so me I'm like hey do this do this
as she goes but I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna get a treat and when we split the
treat that's not what I learned that's
[ __ ] that has never ever won whoever
told you that is working he has millions
of views I don't give a [ __ ]
maybe he got some really good puppies
but every
that I learned I could I'd like training
dogs in the way that dogs train other
dogs right hmm so when a dog has
boundary issues dogs let other dogs know
boundaries because dogs are very tonal
they understand tone mm-hmm so that's
why when my dog
I've never really hit them maybe it
works because you have that more like
strong see but see there you go that's
important though with dogs dogs feed off
of energy yeah a hundred percent you
could ask any dog trainer that they
understand feed off of energy so that's
why when you when you punish them or not
punish the more you let them know what a
boundary is you have to be firm with
this yeah when you first got the dog you
had the hardest time you're just like
hey don't do that like I said it's my
first puppy Ashton why can't you
understand that I did that's how I got
this dog okay I got it
I understand what I'm saying is is she
if you I think the audience can agree if
somebody asks you for advice and in the
meet their immediate response is to
disregard you as if what you're saying
is dumb it's like why'd you ask me in
the first place I agree that is what it
I just don't think I did that son of a I
swear no I have to go along with him cuz
he remembers things better than I do yes
because my heart was torn to pieces some
Marge Simpson what the hell was that
I was thinking the Simpsons but not hit
not marched it was huh about Nelson
Nelson Nelson
yeah the hillbilly bully yeah exactly
she's a bully thank you very much
odd character dude I will never
understand you well I don't know you
might have to stick with one for rest of
your life or like I said I told him
today I was like hey you should really
think about if you want this girl nah
that's not what I said I asked her I
thought what I said I what I said was I
would like to be with somebody who's
very nice and she or she said she's you
might have to find somebody else that's
not what you said I say you might have
to you might have to think about whether
or not you want to be with this girl
exact same you could just be a nice
person
I am nice okay look at that pause no I'm
trying to make sure i phrase this right
that's why I am nice because okay
there's a lot of requests that I give to
him for housework because which I do he
has told me last night actually that my
hands feel like his feet and it's
because I do a lot of cleaning in the
house doesn't my hands feel rough too
because I go okay I excuse me excuse me
your skin got a lot better thanks to me
so I try to find ways to ask him so that
he would here's the thing though we've
talked about this you ask finding in
Magan too early don't allow anybody you
don't allow somebody she doesn't allow
some money to succeed so what she does
is nothing give it I'm like stop talking
when I'm talking he wouldn't you
literally just missed me earlier but
anyway it's all payback no it's not
payback is she doesn't allow people to
succeed what she can do
but she can't do what she can do is
allow me to do it but what she does is
she likes to pick at the negativity
first with for allowing me to succeed I
have wrinkles all over my face because
of you your face is so shiny and flat
okay the surface is smooth oh do you
understand how my half the time we fight
is because I don't know what language
she's speaking she goes your face is so
shiny and flat I'll say did you just
call me a pen face girl and she goes no
flat as if there's no wrinkles so your
skin is smooth who the [ __ ] would have
ever known that that's what they would
behead Amy here
explain that to me there's nobody in
this audience right now when you said
your face is so shiny and flat they
thought oh she means he got no wrinkles
super late at night whether is in the
day whether is I can't really it's all
the same my brain is farting what the
[ __ ] just adding on to that that's that
this girl has highest [ __ ] I can ever
Alpo el loco and she doesn't know where
she's at right now Larry's at night if
you try to have me drive at night so my
co-workers and friends know that I Drive
like I'm high mmm
so doing this sober I just kind of I'm
just kind of delirious cuz I'm so tired
and Slade who segues into the fact that
she used to get mad at me because I told
her she was a bad driver even though she
knows it
see he always needs to say everything
gotta get off his chest regardless never
gives in never gives in how are you got
a load together huh me huh
be nice to me I'm always nice to you see
you know what mmm can I just tell you I
will say this I will be nicer nice sir I
have been nice I will be nicer how would
you like me to ask you when we have to
do tours I did enjoy I just don't know
it at the time that you want there is an
example I'd be like hey kini clean the
toilet cuz that's the only duty he has
as of now a side cooking coz he's what
amazing every time you get an Amazon box
order who's the one that chops it up
those every single one of your 80,000
boxes up I'm sorry who made the bed
recently oh you made the bed who logged
it up there who someone got the bed and
had to sell it and all because someone's
go back was aching oh it wasn't mine I
got the bed for you hon you see well you
know what point you're proving right now
is that
new things pretty equally but yeah but
you disregard the fact that I do things
it was a joke okay that was no joke
people as real as it gets
welcome to your therapy everybody
welcome to David summer Vickery okay
anyway so my going back to my story
chores
I asked Tours are split between two
people did you hear this [ __ ]
you think she's joking but it's real
should it be about some friend points it
should be about harmony like you do the
floor clean mean I take out the trash I
take you would also clean though after I
would clean the second floor so far it's
been me cleaning the first aniseh or not
so true at all
David that David shame itself why we
couldn't do it because he had so much
crap on the floor from your damn dog and
all the stuff as she's dreaming dreaming
retina speaking noise I think she said
that we're bickering she's like I want
some peace she's a light sleeper she's a
weirdo anyways guys to have a healthy
relationship find yourself a partner
that does didn't bring you down doesn't
say that you don't help around the house
even though you do all the time and has
realistic expectations of you and learns
how to communicate without being mean so
do you want to be with this person I
wasn't talking about you I was just
giving generally yeah yes you guys why
do you go into such a place of
everything that we were talking about so
I want to say I want to say you're
coming from a very dark place a - you
are in a cave right now and right now I
am I am the flashlight that's live in
the way and you are trying to take the
batteries out of my flashlight Wow Elmo
what's wrong with it being a backlight
huh look at that look at that is also a
bigot let me tell you this right now
uh-huh yeah hot I'll snip you right
execute all right if it confirmed
you gotta execute anyways guys this
wraps up this episode of the Jesus brain
podcast you just basically heard two
people pick her for about an hour
apologies no apologies this is how it is
in the polar opposite I say yes he said
no you could find Muriel at Muriel
underscore underscore song and you can
find me at genius brain everything
remember every Thursday Sunday there's a
new episode we're here to entertain you
with a bunch of [ __ ] make you laugh
sometimes make you cry and sometimes
make you think I'll see you all next
time
matinee